Can daily copy edibles cause colon issues or bowel issues over time would
done properly? Um, but anything could cause anything, I guess I wouldn't say
that I don't know when it would ever cause any issues. I mean, you could have
some irritation, even if you do it correctly. Um, you know, we met people
at doing coffee edibles for years on a daily basis and not have any issues. If you
feel irritation or something, you could switch from coffee to something else for
a period of time, um, like, um, tea, animal, like something like that. Or you
could back off on it for a period of time. But, um, yeah, I don't, you know, we
have some people that have been doing it a daily for a long time. So, I don't
know, if you feel like you're having some issues, then possibly.